welcome to the heavy spoilers show it's
your boy definition aka deaf hey there
and it's time to go back to a long time
ago in a galaxy far far away for the
penultimate episode of the mandalorian
throughout this video we're just gonna
be breaking down everything that you
need to know about the new releases
overall plot the Easter eggs that you
may have missed and our theories on what
could be happening in the future
we're finally back to focusing on baby
Yoda and this episode titled the
reckoning well it certainly feels like
that look we'll get into it now
obviously there will be heavy spoilers
here so if you haven't had a chance to
watch episode 7 yet and don't want to
know what happens then I highly suggest
that you turn off now make sure you
subscribe to the channel for breakdowns
like this every day and weekly coverage
on the mandalorian I have spoken without
the way I just want to give a huge thank
you for clicking this video now let's
get into a breakdown of the Mandalorian
okay so episode 7 it pretty much picks
up on the main plot thread that's been
dangled throughout the entire season
that is the battle between the Empire
and babyoh de mando returns to Navarro
comes face to face with some old friends
and overall it makes for a great little
entry that feels like it's got the
series back on track after the side
quests the episode opens with mando in
space traversing the galaxy when once
more he gets a message from grief cargo
who since we last saw him in the sin is
found his city under siege by Imperial
forces the clients numbers have grown
exponentially and grief once returned
order
grief also pays lip service to the fact
that the bounty hunters won't stop
coming for baby Yoda or if he doesn't
stop them and it's a plot element that
we've been kind of predicting over the
last couple of weeks though I didn't
expect it to take this long to get here
grief wants to use baby odor as bait to
draw the client out which will not only
get the Empire off their back but as a
thank you grief will also forgive
everything that happened in the third
episode mando accepts the offer and as
predicted he calls upon the network of
contacts that he's been building
throughout the season making a stop at
saga to see Korra June unfortunately he
doesn't stop by to see a mirror
I kind of have a feeling that if the
show does ever wrap up then mando will
retire to the planet to live out the
rest of his life with the character who
doesn't want a happy ending for him
right not that kind of happy ending
anyway mono tells the ex resistance
shock trooper that the Cline is an
imperial warlord and yep as predicted
with that - it's one of the things that
unites them together
I'll stop patting myself on the back for
things I predicted now as well because
yeah
the plot was a bit obvious it's not
really Watchmen so I'm not very special
for getting this right anyway I loved
seeing her fist fighting for the fun of
it in a bar and she's probably my third
favorite character in the show the alien
that she's going head-to-head with it
also looks like a Dathomiri in which is
the same species as Darth Maul and the
fighter has similar horns and the facial
marks that come with the race car are
bests him easily and quickly joins
forces with mando on the ship mano shows
off his weapons to Cora including
thermal detonators blasters and rifles
here you can see the Rebel Alliance
tattoo symbol on a face much better and
it makes her allegiances a lot more
clearer as last time it was barely
visible mando again learns the hard way
you can't leave baby odor alone and they
decide to travel to avala 7 most notably
Kools ranch for some extra assistance
this kind of reminded me a bit of
obi-wan dropping Luke off at the end of
Revenge of the Sith just from the way
that some of the shots looked and it's
nice to remind ourselves that there's
still good people out in the galaxy they
don't leave baby Yoda with the character
but the moments are definitely similar
we also learned that cool was a slave
for the Empire that worked in gene farms
and that he was sold to them as a
servant and had to earn his freedom by
working over three human lifetimes mono
says baby Oda may be a strand cast but
cool rebuffs this saying that it's far
too evolved and that it wasn't formed so
yeah the theory of baby Oda being a
clone of Yoda that's now out the window
we're also no closer to learning about
the origins of the Yoda species where
they come from and so on since the
events of the first episode though cool
discovered IG 11 and reprogrammed it in
order to serve Him this is a nice little
comment on his slavery and it's a nice
little role reversal for the character
we did know that
IG 11 would be
eventually but for me this was a great
surprise as he in pop up for this
watching it Lin to walk it really makes
you become attached to the character I'm
glad that he's a good guy now as I was
massively looking forward to seeing
Taika Waititi back in the role it's no
longer a hunter but now a protector and
the kind of shows that droids take on a
personality that is governed by the
things around them so yeah bad people
make bad droids which is a nice little
bit of trivia for the Stahl's universe
and it kind of adds a lot of weight as
to why so many people including mando or
distrust the machines maybe maybe we
should just start being nice to them on
the ship mando and Cora arm wrestle and
baby out of mistaking the believes that
she's hurting him and it begins to force
choke her not only does it show that
baby otter is gaining a stronger control
of the force due to the fact that it
doesn't strain him but also it hints
that the character could be leaning more
towards the dark side Bors choking was a
tactic used by Darth Vader and the idea
of raising things the right way which we
saw in RG 11 is also reflected here with
subtext being that perhaps all of the
things mano has gone through have had a
negative effect on the character ku also
mentions that the force was something
that he'd heard rumors about which
exemplifies just how little is known
about it since the fall of the Jedi it
used to be massively prevalent in the
Star Wars universe but now it's all over
and it only exists in folklore and
legend mando and crew arrive on navarro
and grief is waiting for them with three
bounty hunters it's sort of a Mexican
standoff almost with no one really
trusting anyone and everything isn't
easy also when baby odor appears I kind
of got flashes of Lord of the Rings when
Boromir would obsess over middle its
most prized possession baby odor yeah
it's just a lot cuter though by campfire
grief discusses the plan and there's a
nod to the Empire basically just being
made up of mercenaries that will run for
the hills once they lose their paycheck
the conversation is cut short though
when grief is attacked by members of the
local wildlife that looks slightly like
our Canyon dragons from Star Wars law it
kind of reminded me a bit of pitch black
and I loved seeing the creatures
terrorized the camp with laser blasts
and flamethrowers lighting up the night
sky grief is badly poisoned by one of
the creatures but luckily baby odor is
on deck to pour Ceylon
disability was hinted at in the first
episode and apparently the idea of force
healing is gonna be a big plot aesthetic
in the rise of Skywalker with several
characters being able to carry out the
process I think Disney deliberately
introduced it here so that when it
showed up in the film it wasn't
completely unfounded but it makes for a
brilliant moment that adds a lot of
weight ooh why baby Yoda must be
protected at all costs we stand for you
baby Oda in the next scene grief kills
the three bounty hunters that he was
with revealing that this was initially
supposed to be a double-cross he's just
committed a triple cross though and he
reveals that the plan was originally to
hand the kid over and win back good
favor with the client but they decide to
still go ahead with everything in order
to stop the wave of hunters coming after
them so the plan is back on and cool
takes baby Oda back to the ship using
the crib as a decoy
similar to a new hope they use the fake
prisoner thing that they did with
Chewbacca and head towards the location
entering the city they pass scout
troopers and speeder bikes which come
into the ending of the episode to their
surprise there's a lot more
stormtroopers and this certainly shows
that the first order or rather Empire at
this point is starting to build their
forces up upon arriving at the meeting
place the client remarks upon the
mando's best course deal and we kind of
get some lip service paid to the fact
that the Mandalorian purge in which the
Empire tried to take over their home
planet is why their numbers are so low
it also adds a lot of weight to the
theory from last time that the New
Republic is basically just failing at
controlling the galaxy due to their over
reliance on droids and this is why the
galaxy destabilized at the point that
the Empire was able to resume control
once more the client demands that the
baby is shown but an incoming call comes
in from none other than moth Gideon
played by Giancarlo Esposito personally
I believe that this was the one who
approached fennec at the end of the
Tatooine episode and he shows he's
actually behind it all pulling all of
the strings a shootout ensues with there
being far more blaster bolts and are
capable from coming from Lando side and
it turns out that Gideon has stormed the
group with not only stormtroopers but
purge troopers to mando stupidly breaks
radio silence with cool and this alerts
scout troopers who swarm towards the
location
cool is killed off camera before
speeders arrived which ends the episode
now there's two ways to look at what
really happened here which I'll get into
now before we talk about Moff gideon i
have seen some people assume that cool
was killed by IG 11 and like mando said
killers are always killers however
there's no reason why the character
wouldn't have done this on the ship or
at least tried to and if you look at the
concept art for the credits the speed is
chasing and firing at cool so maybe one
of them just got lucky
you also see gideon arrived in a TIE
fighter that has the ability to fold its
wings and this is actually a new model
that we haven't seen before the episode
ends with Gideon having them at
stalemate and it looks like the Empire
finally got what it wanted going forward
though I think next week we'll just be
in all our war between Manos forces and
the Empire while say a massively
outnumbered baby oda is getting brought
to the location and as we know he's
becoming much more versed in the force
being able to use it without straining
himself and even developing offensive
abilities such as force choking actually
think that mono maybe killed or at the
very least heavily damaged due to the
final battle and thus baby yoda will
have to pull its energy to heal him you
also last saw the Mandalorians on
nabarro and i think that they may be hid
now on the planet somewhere after what
the client said they will definitely
have beef with the empire so sing them
all gathered in one place it could be
like christmas for the group i think IG
11 will get involved in the fight as
well as he's just seen his master get
gunned down and no doubt you want to
help mando and baby yoda out it's
definitely gonna go down next week and
with them killing cool off
who knows if anyone will make it out
alive griefs griefs dead though isn't he
yeah griefs probably dead now obviously
i'd love to hear your thoughts on the
Mandalorian episode 7 as well as what
your theories for the future are make
sure you leave them in the comment
section below and if you enjoy this
video then force push that like button
and if you want to see more Star Wars
stuff that make sure you check out our
full breakdown of the entire plot for
the rights of Skywalker would you be
linked at the end this episode was moved
up because of the release of the movie
and it looks like Disney are really
going all in on it
we go over the leaks that have been
confirmed so it's definitely worth
checking out if you want to know more if
you want to come chat to me after the
video that make sure you follow me on
twitter at definition whitey or head
over
- code server which should be linked in
the description below we drop videos on
there early so if you want to see stuff
before anyone else and that's the best
place to be it's free to join and we
have an awesome community so hopefully
they see you over there very soon we're
also giving away a free copy of Joker
which is one of our favorite movies of
the air and all you have to do to be in
with the chance of winning is like the
video make sure you subscribe to the
channel and leave your thoughts in the
mandalorian in the comment section below
the winners gonna be chosen at random on
the 15th of January and a set will be
shipped out from the enter forgets the
prize it's the best of luck to everyone
who takes part this is the channel for
people who are never missing television
so if that's the kind of thing you like
you need to subscribe to definition
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this you've been the best and I'll
see you next time take care peace
you
[Music]